good morning Hank it's Friday it's
question Friday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
[Music]
are you gonna live in Indianapolis
forever
well no I'm gonna spend the vast
majority of forever deceased are you a
rebel no I've always been for the Empire
that's no secret the world needs order
and death stars are you aware that on
average your videos that do discuss
giraffe mating get 10 times more views
than your videos that don't discuss
giraffe mating yeah I don't know what it
is exactly but for some reason as
previously noted people love giraffes
who love giraffes maybe it's because the
mating habits of the giraffe are
profoundly fascinating for instance did
you know and by the way this is all
going to be disturbing when boy giraffes
want to have babies with girl giraffes
the first thing that they do is use
their heads to nudge the girl giraffes
in their lady parts they do this and by
the way Hank you may want to put a
bucket nearby because it causes the girl
giraffes to pee and then the boy
giraffes drink the pee because they can
taste whether or not the girl giraffes
are ovulating half sorry I pictured it I
pictured it are you thinking what I'm
thinking
um if you're thinking that you're in
swilling giraffe sex is the most
profoundly uh neurotic thing you've ever
heard of then yes otherwise you disgust
me
are you trying to take over the world
using muffins and silly string Hank
we've been found out are you going to
come to my graduation party no but where
is it I'll send an emissary are you my
father let me answer your question with
a question are you a nine-month-old west
highland terrier with an indomitable
desire to eat shoes if not no are you
stuck in the labyrinth in the labyrinth
but not stuck are you thinking about
writing more books yes I am contracted
to write at least three more books so
don't worry are you even reading this
well I was but now I'm doing something
else are you an optimist with regard to
the future of humanity well I'm an
optimist in the sense that I think are
relentless attempt to extinguish the
species will fail for the foreseeable
future yay are you Kurt Vonnegut dude I
wish are you Santa No
Santa's black are you Gandalf you shall
not I mean Who am I kidding my wizard
stick is an umbrella also I have big Dan
Dolph calls it a wizard sketch are you
King James ii of england well I'm not
Catholic I'm not British and I don't
have shoulder-length curly hair and if I
did I wouldn't part it in the middle are
you a banana oh come on these questions
are just getting stupid like do I have
some kind
pale exterior that you can peel away and
then find edible meat inside oh yes
but do I thrive in tropical climates oh
my god
I am a banana are you gonna put bubbles
nerdfighting puppy in a video soon are
you shocked Gary da je vais à la
bibliothèque is the only sentence I know
in French therefore I'm probably not
Jacque Terra da are you a 40 year old
version rofl question mark he is a
question that was asked by someone who
doesn't know the proper placement of
question marks are you gonna do your
happy dance immediately after reading my
question yes hey happy 2009